ich sehe nur einen ausweg aus der
situation
ich habe den letzten tagen mehrfach
diskussionen erlebt es immer um die
frage gehen wie können wir wieder im
gespräch mit putin kommen und was können
wir ihnen anbieten meine antwort lautet
nichts die gespräche mit putin sind zu
ende putin muss gestürzt werden durch
einen putsch in moskau und dafür muss
der westen die voraussetzungen schaffen
durch die schärfsten denkbaren aktionen
die man überhaupt verhängt davon sind
wir noch weit entfernt
damit die macht elite in moskau brüchig
wird und sich überlegt wie lange sie
noch loyal mit putin ist und damit sich
dann dinge in gang setzen die wir die
mit dem untergang putins enden drei
punkte will ich ihnen erstens wir
sollten sofort den import von gas öl und
kohle aus russland einstellen sofort die
eu-kommission hat schon vor tagen
errechnet dass diese importe zu
kompensieren werden aus anderen quellen
da werden die energiepreise steigen aber
dieses land ist reich genug um einen
sozialen ausgleich für ärmere menschen
zu finden erster punkt zweiter punkt
es ist ja nur ein kleiner teil der
russischen banken von dem bankensystem
swift ausgeschlossen es ist ein viertel
man glaubt es gar nicht und der westen
tut so als seien es fast alle ein
viertel ist ausgeschlossen unter anderem
ist die gazprombank immer noch in diesem
system und zwar deshalb weil die
deutschen für ihre energie importe gerne
über die gas form geschäfte mit russland
machen dafür kann ich mich nur schemen
ich finde es empörend und ich muss sagen
es ist der gipfel der verlogenheit dass
wir auf der einen seite waffen an die
ukraine liefern und auf der anderen
seite mit deutschen öl und gas geld die
russische kriegsmaschine geschmiert wird
das kann doch wohl nicht im ernst sein
wir müssen uns dafür eine seite
entscheiden und die eine seite jetzt in
diesem krieg ist die ukraine dritter
punkt ich bin überzeugt davon dass wir
zu einem generellen
handelsembargo geschäfts embargo mit
russland übergehen sollten keine importe
mehr keine exporte mehr russland total
isoliert und es gibt große deutsche
unternehmen die schon vorangehen die
autokonzerne liefern keine autos mehr
nach russland siemens hat beschlossen
russland zu verlassen und keine aufträge
von dort mehr entgegen zu nehmen das ist
der richtige weg und das nur das bringt
glaube ich menschen in russland in im
militär in den geheimdiensten dazu über
die frage nachzudenken ob sie nicht
besser mut den abräumen müssten um
irland vor schweren schaden zu bewahren
und falls putin falls das passiert und
gut ihn hinterher noch lebt dann muss
der westen darauf bestehen dass er nach
den haag ausgeliefert wird an den
internationalen gerichtshof der dort
kriegsverbrechen und angriffskriege
behandelt wie er das schon gegen
serbische kriegsverbrecher getan hat
jedenfalls bin ich der meinung kein
zurück zu putin putin muss weg
pauli ich kann nur sagen so
schwierig die lage jedoch ist unser
dramatisch die lage ist finde ich freue
ich mich dass du jetzt auch bei der
ukraine politik auf den richtigen weg
gefunden hast auch wenn es ein bisschen
gedauert hat leider keine alternative
ja nein es ist es ist es ist nur
sozusagen aus symbolisch ein bisschen
dass wir haben ja viel über russland und
die ukraine in den vergangenen wochen
und monaten immer wieder gestritten ich
frage mich halt was wäre passiert und
auch diese frage muss man glaube ich mal
erörtern wenn du wenn andere wenn viele
politiker schon früher in diese richtung
gedacht hätten ob es dann sozusagen
diese katastrophe nicht gegeben hätte
und gleichzeitig frage ich mich
gibt es überhaupt eine chance dass das
so passiert wie du sagst also dass
wladimir putin wirklich stürzen kann da
bin ich unsicher weil ich glaube dass
sozusagen alle generäle um ihn herum
alle geheimdienstler all diejenigen die
ihn die er groß gemacht hat große sorge
haben mit ihm zusammen zu stürzen und
das bedeutet dass der geheimdienst
bereich dass der militärbereich um ihn
herum ein interesse daran hat dass er
bleibt und ich soll das ist das glaube
ich tragische
und wenn wir sehen dass selbst auch
oligarchen
was man zumindest liest natürlich
unglücklich sind darüber wie es verläuft
aber es nicht schaffen werden um ihn zu
stürzen muss man davon ausgehen dass er
bleibt und werden wir die rede hören
über die wir vielleicht gleich auch noch
sprechen können oder die ansprache die
er gehalten hat dann muss an das
wirklich erschaudern lassen und
tatsächlich zittern lassen davor was er
noch mit der ukraine vorher lieber als
irgendwelche lieber paul in italy tät
ich teile deine
bedenken zum teil ich stelle aber fest
es ist völlig unmöglich dass die ukraine
den krieg gegen russland gewinnt das
sind die größten velten ist einfach zu
stark das heißt da muss der westen eine
entscheidende rolle spielen ich gebe dir
zu dass ich mich in der politik
russlands und putins getäuscht habe ich
dachte es geht in wahrheit um die ost
erweiterung der nato da hat der westen
1990 nach der deutschen
wiedervereinigung fehler gemacht da hat
er russland getäuscht aber heute bin ich
froh dass es die ost erweiterung
überhaupt gegeben hat denn sonst wären
diese länder
russland im prinzip ausgeliefert auch
also ich habe erkannt dass die
argumentation mit dem namen lieber nicht
in frage stellen könne ja mach mal eine
frage weil beides gerade anspricht weil
ich ja vorhin auch über die rede von den
oder meiner die antwort von präsident
selensky auf meine frage gesprochen hat
hältst du stand für völlig unrealistisch
dass sie lenski dass in dieser stadt das
gar nicht mehr putin am ende werde mit
der ukraine fertig ist nicht tatsächlich
nach nato staaten greifen wird also wer
sagt denn dass die nato wirklich bereit
steht wenn dann ein vermeintlich kleines
land wie estland also in den baltischen
staaten angegriffen werden würde das
glaube ich nicht und ich will das auch
begründen er hat doch inzwischen
mehrfach programmatisch erklärungen
abgegeben ich glaube dass er erst dann
denkt ehemaligen staaten der sowjetunion
wieder zurückzuerobern das fängt an mit
georgien und das ist nicht mitglied der
nato und ginge dann theoretisch weiter
in messel mittelasiatischen staaten an
den baltischen staaten glaube ich weder
sich nicht vergreifen weil er eben
scheut davor
sich mit der nato anzulegen auch dass
die ukrainische grenze nach westen von
russischen truppen nicht abgeriegelt
wird ist ja ein zeichen dafür dass er
dort mit der nato nicht in konflikt
geraten will er will eben auch über
leben und das müssen wir eben glaube ich
durch andere mittel davon habe ich
gesprochen unmöglich machen er darf
keinen zweiten krieg führen und er darf
diesen krieg nicht gewinnen er muss
untergehen und wenn er nicht und wenn er
nicht sozusagen lebend ausgeschaltet
wird dann muss eben einer im moskauer
machtsystem eine pistole nehmen und der
sache ein ende bereiten wir machen aus
dem einzel von euch beiden mal einen
sockel und irgendwann wieder rüber zu
herablassend herr menikheim einig wenn
sie das hören die frage die sich
natürlich auch sehr sehr viele europäer
stellen ist wird die ukraine wladimir
putin überhaupt reichen wenn er sie
erobert hat
ich kann die meinung von herrn joos in
dieser frage also nicht teilen in dem
sinne dass die ukraine diesen kampf
verlieren kann so sie sah ihn nicht
verlieren denn wenn wenn wenn das
geschieht dann wird es keine ukraine
geben dann ihm geht es nicht nur um
umbesetzung von von gebieten ihm geht um
dass das zerschlagen der staatlichkeit
und das heißt sie und deswegen wir
wissen davon und egal welche
zugeständnisse jetzt von uns verlangt
oder was uns nahegelegt wird auch hier
in berlin dann man sollte sich bewegen
da ist die frage die die antwort es gibt
nichts was putin zufriedenstellen würde
damit er loslässt und deswegen so
vielleicht um das thema herr schröder
abzuschließen wir hätten für ihn und
alle beleidigungen also das bleibt in
der vergangenheit auch für uns aber er
hätte vielleicht doch eine letzte
aufgabe also er ist einer der wenigen
hier in deutschland oder vielleicht der
vielen politiker die womöglich noch
einen direkten draht zu herrn putin hat
also es gibt keinen integrieren
und oder in anderen europäischen ländern
er könnte das vielleicht versuchen und
dann werden wenn es ihm gelingt herrn
putin das klingt natürlich jetzt nicht
sehr realistisch aber dann würde er doch
vielleicht in die geschichte nicht
eingehen als als putin oder bist und
jemand der diesen krieg vielleicht auch
herbeigeführt hat durch seinen handeln
und es geht auch darum dass dass die
politik hier auch reinen tisch macht es
gibt nicht nur herrn schröder es gibt
viele andere banken ganz benötigen
andere manager ganz wird jeder anders
wenn ich eine frage die es zu
vermitteln
heißt dass der botschafter dass sie
wollen dass gerd schröder vermittler wir
zwischen dem westen und russland das ist
ja eine sehr spannende forderung das ist
nur ein kreativer vorschlag herunter das
liegt daran eine schritte wo er jetzt in
dieser position ist wo sich alle von
ihnen verabschieden und abwenden warum
dann nicht also wir müssen jede chance
nutzen und das meine ich ernst ich
glaube nicht dass es etwas zu vermitteln
gibt im ernst putin will die ukraine
erobern und russland einverleiben und
was sollte die kompromiss position sein
ein bisschen erobern anni lenz geben amt
lassen nur die ost ukraine nehmen die
krim behalten und diese und jenes das
ist ihm nicht genug das hätte er links
haben können das geht einfach nicht wir
müssen uns damit abfinden
dieser krieg den putin begonnen hat denn
putin zu ende führen will bei dem er
keine zeichen von rückzug erkennen lässt
muss man gewinnen über putin man muss
putin absolvieren aber deswegen ich
werde wenn noch mal ein punkt heraus
gaben sie haben eben gesagt da die
ukraine ist verloren und da kann man
nicht mehr viel machen ja dieser das
lasst uns das ist herr jörges das halte
ich für einen ganz großen fehler das
öffentlich zu sagen misswahl das haben
wir das haben wir genau das haben wir
von der woche auch gehör teuren sei
mache ein solches laura einmal einmal
kurze zeit außerdem lassen bronze hat
das ja am anfang der sendung auch noch
einmal hervorgehoben es gab in
deutschland ich weiß dass andere aus den
diskussionen im bundestag viele die
gesagt haben keine defensivwaffen an die
ukraine liefern das wird eh nur zwei
drei tage dauern jetzt sehen wir diesen
heroischen kampf des ukrainischen volkes
und wir sehen die brauchen weitere
unterstützung wir brauchen weiter waffen
wenn die jetzt aber von uns hören naja
eigentlich sind die schon verloren und
das vielleicht den putin sogar da mal
machen aber wir gucken dass der dann
nicht weitermacht dann wäre das ein ganz
ganz schlechtes signal zumal putin ja
nicht nur die ukraine angreift sondern
ergreift damit auch unsere
demokratischen werte an er greift unsere
freiheit an und er wird sich damit
möglicherweise nicht zufriedengeben
wollen wir hätten wir hätten wir uns vor
drei wochen hier in der sendung
getroffen hätten sie und andere
wahrscheinlich gesagt na putin wird ihn
nach kiew einmarschieren das wird ja gar
nicht wagen sondern da hätten viele
gesagt na ja vielleicht in die hand
sondern gemacht eine noch weiß erinnert
haben viele gesagt so und jetzt sehen
wir was putin alles macht und wir wissen
aus der geschichte solche diktatoren
solcher autokraten solche verrückten die
machen meistens nicht nur bei einem land
teilt und deswegen müssen wir eine
stärke entwickeln und wir müssen mehr
ins militär investieren wir müssen die
ukraine jetzt unterstützt und die
meisten gab mir das jetzt vortragen ich
habe nichts anderes gesagt ich meinte
damit natürlich kann putin militärisch
die ukraine setzen wenn er mit einem so
guten eindruck als sie an die eu alleine
nicht weil er wird immer auf widerstand
stößt es wird immer sie einigen
sitzungen geben
sie einmal mitnehmen die die die genau
die situationen hier gerade in diesem
moment nach langer ruhe wieder
sirenenalarm zumindest gerade einmal
hier
jetzt hören sie essig lassen immer leise
so hatte sich der sirenenalarm in kiew
an
das was wir auch schon vor zwei tagen
gehört haben also das ist die realität
für die bevölkerung hier jeden tag
insbesondere dann wenn es dunkel wird
ich habe schon mal erklärt wir haben ein
weiteres sicherheitssystem ausgestattet
auch mit apps ähnlich wie in israel wo
gewarnt wird von luftschlägen von daher
gehen wir beim ich sage mal
einfacheren
luftalarm noch nicht in den bunker
sondern warten ein bisschen aber ich
glaube diese stimmung muss man einmal
verstehen die wirklich grauenhaft ist
für die menschen hier ich möchte herrn
flossen berechnung von paar geben wir
ganz kurz in hier in einer ganz kurzen
unterbrechung lassen auch noch die
sirenen nachhaltig auf uns wirken und
hoffen dass paul dann auch gleich uns
noch zugeschaltet ist es
selbstverständlich nicht zu einem
zweiten alarm compal bis gleich